so I wanted to make a quick video to
thank Gary Vaynerchuk for all the hustle
and the love and the contributions that
is making to the entrepreneur community
he has a really popular YouTube channel
and it's one of the only ones that i
watch consistently have watched every
single videos put out have commented and
liked a whole bunch of them I first
connected with Gary back in 2009-2010
when I was making a line of famous
entrepreneur trading cards for charity
and I asked him Gary who was your
favorite famous entrepreneur and he said
Vince McMahon and so we created the
Vince McMahon card number 4 in series
then I connected with Frank Gruber and
that's him who his favorite famous
entrepreneur was and he said Gary
Vaynerchuk so Gary has his own card as
well number 26 in the series and we used
that money to raise over a hundred
thousand dollars for entrepreneurs in
Africa to get their businesses started
and so since then Gary's had a big
impact on my business and I love
watching these videos almost every
single day so give it a thank you for
all your contributions I gathered some
of your loyal fans and they had a quick
message to share Gary Vee you are a
force you scare me you inspire me you
motivate me you are an extraordinary guy
you haven't helped me you've helped your
audience you've helped the social media
universe I just think you've lost too
much weight you need to beef it up again
Gary you're the man I want to give a
huge thank you to Gary Vaynerchuk
especially for his book crush it which
was the catalyst behind my success as a
youtuber after reading that book my
hustle hard started working hard
following his advice and I took my
youtube channel from about 2,000
subscribers to over a hundred thousand
subscribers with 10 million views thank
you Gary I couldn't done it without you
hey Gary this is antwon would add mini
solution thanks a million men I've been
watching every single episode since day
one I love everything you do your your
show is a drug to me I need my fix I
need at least a couple of shows a week
and I really look forward to 200 300
episode Thank You min hey Gary this is
Derek shomer I just wanted to give a
word of thanks for all the videos that
you've done over the years I started
watching the way back on
Wine Library I think when you're on
revision3 around that time period and
I'm since then you've inspired me to
create not only an online show around
our YouTube channel all the social that
goes around with it but to have grown
our YouTube channel 60 thousand plus
subscribers and since then other people
have created shows inspired by what I've
done so they've done things inspired by
me I've done things inspired by you so
when you're searching on YouTube and you
find a cocktail how-to video that goes
through tasting notes and explanations
in history think about it like this you
with a little bit of me we changed how
cocktails are created on YouTube have a
good day hey Gary I just wanted to say
thank you I mean I could oh my god I
could list the ways and it would just be
way too many my friend you know what
they are thank you thank you for giving
so much to the vaynernation to my life
it has been a complete joy all of these
years hey Gary it's roberto from roberto
blake calm thank you so much for all the
tremendous value create for me and
everybody else in the vaynernation
watching at home thank you also to Evan
Carmichael for making this great video
to allow us to say thank you to you and
give you a shout out Gary speaking of
shoutouts thank you so much for the
shout out in episode 66 totally
unexpected and tremendous I was so glad
to be a part of the askgaryvee show
anyway this is roberto blake from
Burnett calm and remember Gary create
something awesome today hey Gary your
advice has helped me so much you're
amazing thank you mwah see you when I
get to New York
g to the beep a little thank you all the
way from Cape Town South Africa where
good wine comes from for answering my
question on episode 104 the one with the
bucket your answer this question of you
thanks for that but you know I also
thank you india for adding my name into
the bucket that's it come here with some
have some wine with us in cape town
sometime soon and we'll see you in New
York for the life forming of episode 200
hey Gary just wanted to say hi hello
from Sydney to everyone not only to Gary
but to all the finer nation I just
wanted to thank you for all the content
that you put out every day they're very
valuable so thank you so much cheers
Gary Coffey salute to you from poet all
the best hey Gary sacks I from Stockholm
Sweden here and I want to thank you for
the amazing books and videos and also
for creating such an amazing community
around them whenever I feel like I'm
climbing that hill alone I can always
turn to these amazing people and get
some feedback and ideas so I want to
thank you for that and also a big
shout-out to Carmichael for making this
video happen and i want to wish you a
kick-ass created a high game is your son
even India I just want to say a big
thank you to you I don't think you can
understand the impact of the impact
you've had on my patio business it's
almost a given a mentor to me so big
thank you please keep doing what you do
ok I just want to say thanks to Gary Vee
for the inspirational videos keep up the
good work it's helping a lot of people i
got my what's the ROI of your mother
shirt on anyway keep up the good work
and i hope you buy the jets Gary its we
past midnight and we past the deadline
for this video but I still want to take
the opportunity thank you why because it
doesn't matter where you are whether
your honor
playing on the street during jury duty
you take the time to make content for us
so the least least I could do is thank
you for everything is done everything
thanks a lot hey Gary it's your good
friend Adam ivy and I just wanted to
take a quick second to thank you
personally for the positive influence in
the path of mentorship that you've
provided me over the years through your
videos and your articles your books and
obviously the continuous social
interaction it's inspired me to become
the Gary Vaynerchuk of my generation and
for that it means a lot and i genuinely
appreciate it shoot me an email and
follow me on twitter at adam IV and
we'll see you around hey Gary Vee hey
Gary Vee she is one of my five kids and
the reason why I do what I do thank you
for your Gary Vee show thank you for
your books thank you for your blog thank
you for the advice encouragement and all
that you do keep up the good work I'll
be watching hey Gary rich here from blue
stripe creative at the blue stripe on
Twitter trying to thank you for all that
you do all the podcasts all the books
all the social media post your true
inspiration to business owners such as
myself since the first day that open my
business keep doing what you're doing
pal appreciate it Alighieri you have any
idea who I am turns its matts against
being a question Thank You Tube and
thanks a lot for your answers your
honesty thank you arrhenius thanks Gary
sup Gary Dave co-ceo from Dave cozy or
calm what's going on Gary Vee Steve
raking here coming to you from Boston
Mass just got done almost done with the
millionaire attentive seminar in we just
want to come to you and say thank you so
much you've added so much value to my
life and a number one thing I got from
you is always give give give and
over-deliver so thank you so much Gary
Vee yeah Gary thank you so much to the
number one thing that you've helped me
with and really inspire me to do is just
be able to be myself and be able to feel
and know that I can actually create a
business around my passion and do what
it was that I truly want to do and just
be myself because it's so transparent
and everything you put out there you
were one hundred percent totally just
result so thank you so much again and
we'll talk to you by hey Gary Robert
from Miami here traveling Robert at you
too
and just a good video to say thank you
for all your videos for all the
knowledge and wisdom you have spread
over the years it's been almost 12
almost 10 years that first you tell us
about why now you're teaching us how to
succeed in business so for that thank
you gary david haye from Scotland here
from all things you've probably seen me
over the last sort of six months follow
you engage keeping up the hustle so just
wanted to say a massive thank you we're
big fans over here in Scotland and yeah
keep up the good work mate Cheers hi
this is Amanda oh sorry over Mitchell
intellectual property law thanks Gary
for answering my question and thank you
to the Gary Vee team for everything you
guys do we really appreciate you girthy
what's up man VV my name is Tim black
attempts take live here on YouTube man I
got to tell you first of all you're the
man i'm not i'm not saying that lightly
don't take it like me I mean it look
when I need information when I need
substance that fluff at the fluffy stuff
people just say cuz it sounds good what
I need the real deal I don't go anywhere
but Gary Vee the Gary Vee show that's it
all right so look man I know do you have
a lot going on one you got a lot on your
plate I want to thank you for taking
time out to help me you don't even know
me and you helped me you inspire me
thank you sir Gary my best here long
time fun and thanks to even Carmichael
here to say thank you I thought I'd just
choose one specific thing and that's
saying thank you for introducing me to
this this is Jurgen das la pelea which
you did on a Wine Library TV show with
kermit lynch I went out and bought a
dozen bottles and for drinking one
bottle here since 2010 so thank you for
that at three hundred percent with
monday motivation love the askgaryvee
show Gary thank you hey Gary thank you
working like a dog and arsenic who knows
maybe you can also more than 50 cent
thanks for the Cambodian islands and
hope see you in London soon man love to
catch up what's up Gary be just want to
say thank you Chris Smith here you
actually were willing to put your name
on a self-published book that we wrote
and you know we have a good relationship
but you kind of put your neck out there
and the book went on to sell you know
more than 17,000 copies it's a huge hit
and it's all because you really do live
a people work lifestyle you've helped so
many people that don't even know you you
know my friend he called me when I first
heard about you he's like hey I'm at
this event you got it you got to look
this guy up his name's Gary Vee I'm like
what do you like about him he's like he
just told forty percent of the room that
they're in the wrong industry and I just
what online I remember that digital
trench gary was so deep and so wide with
so much great content that i bought
crush it bought the e-book bought the
book you know thank you economy been a
fan you've been a mentor from afar
you've touched so many people's lives so
thank you for everything you've done
Thaksin hey Gary I've been following you
since about the time you started the
askgaryvee show since then you reminded
me of some things i'd forgotten and you
told me some new way it's looking thing
most of all you've helped me get focused
again you even got me on instagram you
turkey your jabs are plentiful and your
right hooks are rare rare enough that i
almost feel guilty absorbing all the
wisdom you've shared I wonder if you
really realize how much difference is
made for those of us
click with her advice from the tractor
so thanks Gary for being you now fill me
what can I do for you hey Gary Vee I
just want to say thank you personally so
much for being such an inspiration that
mad hard tough but fair self-love talk
that you do has inspired me in the way
that I self-talk and and self motivate
and now become even more self-aware
about who I am and what my strengths are
your voice is always ringing in my head
and I always kind of infect everybody
around me have you heard of Gary Vee
just the voice just the message to have
that in the air in the atmosphere as I'm
creating my content is just one of those
things that's part of my routine black
coffee Gary Vee thank you so much for
everything you do keep rocking and I
can't wait to see what happens in the
future peace hey Gary this is dan shore
in Worcester Massachusetts I want to
thank you especially for your advice on
listening to people in Twitter having
conversations around topics in your
industry and try to be helpful I did
this and came up with a blog post idea
because i was listening to people wanted
to provide value that blog post has
generated thirty thousand visits actual
direct business from people discovering
me through that piece of content and i
could not have been ever that anger
advice so thank you for all the things
that you do for the entrepreneur and
marketing communities it is very much
appreciated thank you is it on
hey Gary it's dawn dogaru so I just
wanted to send a huge thank you for all
the amazing content you created over the
years since Wine Library I've loved
every minute of it and been able to use
so much of it for my business thanks hey
Gary just wanted to say thanks for all
the content you put out there and the
great information even now here in the
country working in agriculture it's
valuable to us so we appreciate it and
thanks again for all you do hi Jerry at
and RuPaul stone from Portland Oregon
now in barcelona spain i want to say a
big thank you for everything you've done
for vaynernation hey Gary just wanted to
say thank you so much for everything
that you invest into your community the
content you're putting out on a regular
basis isn't just great content it's a
huge inspiration to those of us trying
to hustle alongside with you so thank
you so much for everything you do man I
appreciate it Gary Vee man you've given
me one of your greatest assets your time
I really appreciate it so grateful
actually so grateful in fact I'm willing
to get a ticket just trying to thank you
because I'm definitely not driving
hands-free here in California but thank
thank you my man good gay hey Gary Jimmy
Fisher here and I wanted to say thank
you so much for all that you poured into
me over the years all the value of
created for me being a loyal veiniacs
since pre crush it days and the best way
I could say thank you is to put what
you've taught me in action and I've done
that with my digital agency juice box
and why that's ju c eb 0 x and I'm
actually opening a bar with my brother
the Wilkey in brooklyn in 2015 so all
about experiences for our customers
there to appreciate you thank you so
much hey Gary it's Tom Pellegrino at
tagline Tom and I want to thank you very
much for putting on the podcast they're
awesome they're great advice for people
who have questions regardless of what
field are in marketing media or in my
case HR and it's great to know that when
we have questions you answer them this
video is just to say thank you to gary
vee for his continued commitment to his
community through the askgaryvee show
every episode is inspirational
motivational and educational Gary Vee
thank you for all that you do hey Gary I
I wish I look better for this and had a
better background yeah I we want to
express my appreciation for you and for
everything you've done for not only me
but everybody out there you give the
purest advice and Express pure thoughts
and you tell us to keep on hustling and
that's what we're gonna do you know I
hope you have a great summer and yeah
keep on being healthy and just take care
of an hey Gary this is Sam Eldon from
Toledo Ohio I've been following your
work since the wine library TV days and
now with the askgaryvee show it's really
really helpful to me I run a small
nonprofit soweto and everything you say
your homework it's really great so thank
you so much I found Gary Vaynerchuk
through several different pathways first
of video creators I love video creators
with Tim Schmoyer and then he suggested
Evan Carmichael and I love ever
Carmichael he's so inspirational it
makes you tubing and trying to be an
entrepreneur so much more so much less
lonely to have people that are saying
they're going through the same thing and
there to support each other and so I
watch Evan Carmichael and he suggested
Gary Vaynerchuk did I say it right I
think I gotta write Vaynerchuk I love to
watch him he's so full of energy and
pizzazz and just a you can do it
personality I've really enjoyed watching
his videos so thank you to all of you
out there who inspire me and hopefully
you will continue to have the success
that you've had up to this point thank
you hey gary vee scout and rob from coin
up TV just want to say what's up thanks
for all your advice on hustling and
learning how to play the game take care
hey Gary Vee is Bridget Willard from you
too can be a guru I just wanted to say
thanks for all of your hard work and
your free information and your daily
marketing classes on the askgaryvee show
it's really encouraging
for somebody like me who doesn't have a
journalism or marketing degree who's
self-taught in social media to see
someone so successful who also doesn't
have those degrees so we appreciate you
and we're thankful for all your hard
work and all that you do to encourage
all of us is small business remember you
too can be a guru I Gary Dillon here
from South Africa I just wants to say a
quick thank you wanted to say thank you
for being a brand beacon in our industry
being open being honest just pushing the
envelope and driving others to be better
thank you so much chah-e gary vaynerchuk
its Gigi here just shouting out a huge
thank you chase got a positive es por
ski I wanted to say thank you for
sharing your knowledge for showing
people that being successful also means
being grateful and humble and thank you
for my new friends whom I met here in
Poland thanks to your askgaryvee show
Jim quia hey guys Luis Foreman coming to
you live from Boston thank you for run
doing the askgaryvee show it's my
question and episode 88 and just giving
us great ideas and things that we can do
to improve our clients business but also
inspire and I'm going to go listen your
podcast again and again again thanks
Gary Gary what's up brother Jason
Goldberg here hey just wanted to give
you a quick shout ever since I met you
at full sail university years ago and
you were giving a talk and I said you
look like and sounded like Charlie day
from its always sunny in philadelphia
and you had no clue who I was talking
about at all I've been following you and
you know what man I don't always agree
with what you're saying and that doesn't
matter because you always make me think
you always provoke me and have me
question what I'm doing my level of
commitment what it is that I agree with
the world what it is that I don't agree
with in the world and why so I can
really grow and become a better person
and a more successful person in the
world and have a deeper impact for the
people that I work with so dude I thank
you for the work you're doing in this
world it does so much for so many people
lots of love to you and keep it up bro
Boosh it's the polish gift from 100th
episode thanks for putting out so much
great content and i can't wait during it
read your next book so thank you Gary
for your hustle for your contributions
to the entrepreneur community as you've
seen you've made a big impact on a lot
of people thank you so much belief
you